mentalise mois à salut à vous peuple d
internet une toute petite annonce très
rapide avant de commencer cette vidéo
j'ai fait le spectacle de création du
nouveau spectacle mentale rodage pendant
cent dates en province et vous avez des
nombreux à me demander pourquoi n'y
avait pas ne serait-ce qu'une seule date
à paris beaucoup tu peux moi tu voulais
dire c'est parce que j'avais pas prévu
mais à la demande générale
et comme j'ai aussi besoin de faire des
images pour le nouveau spectacle je fais
une date exceptionnelle à paris le 29
octobre
tom poti dimanche des familles c'est à
19 heures je vous mets le lien dans la
description c'est une petite salle
parisienne on prendra le temps de se
rencontrer à la fin mai comme c'est
petit ça va vite partir donc situé à
paris le 29 octobre que tu veux voir ce
nouveau spectacle et que tu veux qu'on
se doit après c'est maintenant ou jamais
en fait voilà c'est tout et maintenant
j'ai le plaisir le kiff d'être avec emi
ltr on s'était parlé plusieurs fois que
ça on avait fait des événements ensemble
et on s'est fait une petite vidéo des
familles qui va suivre
je le remercie mille fois d'être ici
j'ai essayé de la mentalité est ce que
ça va bien se passer ou pas vous allez
voir mais c'est drôle c'est que lie to
me c'est la meilleure série de
mentalisme quand on veut dire que la cei
le mentalist c'est un monteur exactement
pourquoi parce que j'étais sûr que sheen
allemande et que parfois je fais des
chutes de the mentalist c'est le
fantasme de base quoi c'est vraiment le
mec qui te regarde et dit où il a
toujours tout juste dans la réalité
tiens là on va faire un truc je le mets
ma commence à transpirer puisque je ne
sais pas si je passe ici assez horrible
parce que j'espère vraiment que tu vas
te planter j'ai envie de dire je sais
pas tout le monde me dit ça chez dédé ce
sera fait de fierté personnelle de dire
je tends chimiques et non mais moi je
suis faible je suis super fier faible
nombre de remakes si faible
l'affiché super expressive du coup c'est
très facile de savoir je suis un livre
vert au staff
moi je me suis dit ce qu'on peut faire
c'est deviner son code de carte bleue
mais si je donne ton titre de carton
code de carte bleue et noisy quand même
tu vois ouais on pourrait faire en sorte
soit que tu prennes les quatre derniers
chiffres de ta carte bleue par exemple
les résidents invente un code à quatre
chiffres mais on dit que c'est ton code
de carte bleue pour aujourd'hui et ce
sera dans le titre et là vous rendre
quand que c'est pas son vrai code à
partir de maintenant mais tu as cliquer
c'est beaucoup trop tard et oui le
[ __ ] qui paye
alors allez voir la dernière vidéo démis
peut-être que c'est pas la dernière
mais je vous mettrais une vidéo en lien
l'inscription aller voir ce que ce n'est
pas la terre parce qu'on ne sait pas
quand on va me soulier oui cette vidéo
écoute moi tu sais je suis dispo et puis
je pas une vidéo d'apprendre civetta
caggiano placerait ses lacets
l'australie veut rien dire les excuses
mais plus moisi du monde si l'australie
c'est pour ça c'est un il parle quand
#obama êtes jamais dit que je serais
calme je suis cannes - bodmer jeu mais
pas de montage je laisserais tous très
bien mais ça va tu sais moi j'ai pas de
problème avec moi tu sais faire trop de
soucis et le lac sans rien c'est fou et
en plus ils étaient 2000 allemand demi
celui-ci de trait est parfois j'arrive
même inséré le belge envisage un
mentaliste on a dit mentalise alors on
invente un code de carte bleue
dira-t-on ce sera ton code de carte
bleue pour aujourd'hui il peut-être
inspiré de faits réels c'est à dire de
sa date de naissance à peu des trucs
comme ça mais je te le déconseille de le
mieux c'est de prendre un truc
complètement rangs des hommes ou quasi
en sommes mais il va falloir que tu t'en
souviennes donc tu inventes à un code à
quatre chiffres dans ta tête
ok tu me dis quand c'est bon et quand tu
penses que tu es capable de le retenir
c'est bon ok je suis allé chercher ça et
je me suis dit que pour trouver donc
quand on allait utiliser les micro
mouvements musculaires
donc on va commencer par des squats
alors sur ce petit bloc notes comme vous
pouvez le constater j'ai écrit un deux
trois quatre cinq six sept huit neuf
zéros va me prendre le poignet un peu
comme si tu me prenais le coutumes et
deux doigts en dessous ou au dessus
comme ça ok d'accord tu cherches pas
guidé ma main quand je passe mon doigt
par exemple si là je fais rien voir si
je le passe sur un de tes chiffres à toi
tu te dis dans ta tête suis là en fait
partie
oui un truc
c'est pas bien du tout dans cette vidéo
soit là des chiffres qui sont dans les
extrêmes et du coup je vais leur mélange
et pour voir ce qui se passe je sache
que je suis surdouée
je suis moi-même mentalist que je n'en
ai pas parlé tout à fait et que je sais
moi aussi je pense pas et puis la tonne
qu'il était possible que je vais mener
pas d'âme
mais comme ça on va passer ça comme ça
je regarde même temps oui bah oui c'est
un peu con sinon ça n'a aucun sens j'ai
assez de pression moi ça va bouger le
bloc notes
pour l'instant je vous le dis je vois je
vois pas ce que je fais mais par contre
comme ça ça me permet de tenir là comme
quoi je n'ai pas de réaction aux bons
endroits
ok alors par contre ça fait plusieurs
fois que toi inconsciemment mais c'est
normal tu m'emmènes vers la du coup je
veux un jour et moins et ce petit rire
agacé nous fait me signifier y adhérer à
quelque part il ya du un quelque part
ok allez je vais essayer d'en avoir je
suis si faible jamais sur les deux
peut-être que je tends tu as des rares
mais en face il y avait pas de deux je
pense que j'aurais eu la joie certains
visages un mode jeu les troubles c'est
vraiment elle vraiment genre de
personnage n'a vraiment pas envie de
passer la soirée mais qui s'exerce que
tu penses un dacquois l'accord
continuons
est ce que tu peux répondre à une
question dans ta tête ouais est ce que
un ou plusieurs chiffres sont doublés ok
donc j'ai du neuf du 2 juin
je suis fan de mort je suis content d
avoir le contenu j'ai le souci situe la
gare est gelée déjà c'est sûr que j'ai
douté
[Musique]
olala c'est elle c'est beaucoup trop
influençable moi même on peut me donner
le nom mais ce fait je vais partir de là
tu vas répondre pour de vrai conte de
manière verbale conscient fait tourner
est-ce que cet ensemble de chiffres a du
sens pour toi ou pas non c'est
complètement en sommes ouais ok ça
marche mais mais fou ça fait bien fait
puisque avec samedi c'est le thème de
cette vidéo je compte amis tout je me
rends compte que c'est quand je galère
ils trouvaient la suite que j'utilise la
chaîne vidéo tu vois ma fille 48 ans et
demi après tu vas penser que au bâton
premiers chiffres et tu vas me dire neuf
de 1 9-2 comme ça en boucle jusqu'à
temps que je t'arrête vous pouvez
repasser ce petit passage en boucle vous
aussi pour deux raisons la première
c'est que ça va augmenter au wat stein
et ça c'est cool et la deuxième raison
c'est que vous allez entendre la manière
de la line up de 1,9 2,1
en fait tu as fait exactement neuf de
1,9 2,1 teva ce que c'est l'allemagne
c'était à aa mais moi je pense que c'est
chamassy trahi je vois surtout c'est du
pléonasme de penser c'est à dire que
quand tu pensé quelque chose et que tu
le dis tu le mets en valeur ces partis
mais pas le deuxième donc mais le
deuxième chiffre à un petit peu en fond
en mode de pensée puis tu fais 9 de 1,9
de 1,9 de hockey cette foule on le fait
par le troisième
oui tu mets le troisième dans le fond de
ta tête et c'est parti ok j'hésite entre
deux donc je vais les mettre
et le dernier mot car cette vidéo ça me
fait rire ça me fait rire c'est ben ça
me fait rire c'est une angoisse maximale
monte à l'intérieur de moi de en fait
j'ai pas du tout les bons chiens elle se
dit et là quand il va en tournée vous
allez bien d'ailleurs
ok bon je pense en tout cas avoir le
dernier
ok mais j'ai un gros doute sur le
troisième donc le seul code qui compte
c'est parce que c'est pas les notes que
j'ai pris c'est celui que j'ai encadré
et militaires
oui symbolisant tant de familles par
trois consonnes est-ce que s'il vous
plaît sans vouloir trop vous commandez
vous pourriez avoir l'obligeance en
tourner autour du pot et sans essayer de
passer par quatre chemin parce que je
suis complètement sûr de moi oui ta joie
est ce que vous pourriez me donnez votre
code de carte bleue en quatre chiffres
s'il vous plaît 12 13 12 13 cg29 n'a
jamais été présent ce que tu m'as
diefenthal et je dis bon le font sourire
[ __ ] tu étais pas par contre je suis
pas mal c'est à dire que que mon oeuvre
ce qui a trois bons élèves
je considère avoir réussi à donc 75 %
maintenant elle a déjà je suis surprise
que tu avais réussi à trouver et est ce
que dans une enveloppe j'avais pas
marqué qu'en fait je ferai une erreur
exprès au dernier très bien non il est
trop chaud ouais
c'est hallucinant ton poignet et justes
en écoutant ce que je dis c'est quand
même incroyable
en tout cas tu as bien caché que j'étais
en train de me tromper pendant neuf
heures est ce que je n'ai pas vu dit ou
non en fait c'est toi c'est toi qui m'a
aidé à cacher en fait parce que comme tu
m'as dit des choix oui j'ai débuté au
fur à mesure
voilà je savais qu'en faisant ça moi
j'ai un grand des roches pourquoi je
fais ça non malgré tout la déduction du
coup j'ai c'est induire en erreur en
faisant des choses que tu avais
conseillé en faisant l'inversé en
spectacle fait la même chose c'est à
dire que comme j'adore le mentaliste
mais j'adore transmettre j'explique
offert mesure comment ça se passe alors
que je n'ai pas fini mon coup de bluff
on va dire que je devrais tu vas
apprendre à fermer ma bouche soit
semaine me tromper j'assume de me
tromper
voilà c'est pas très grave merci aussi à
tort franchement c'est trop moche et
très très courtois et merci définition
hnc coude ah oui et puis alors danser
sur la mienne aussi parce qu'on fait une
collaboration
c'est à dire qu'il va peut-être trouvé
mon 52 xiam faut dire qu on crée d'abord
en colère je ne cautionne pas cette
vidéo qui est bon je sais pas comment
finir cette vidéo assis toi si tu es
gêné des abonnés de la chaîne vous merci
beaucoup d'avoir regardé c'est une sorte
d'habitude vous pouvez cliquer ou vous
abonnez mais surtout vous abonner
également à la chaîne d'amy non surtout
l' acia et non sens où les tenants cette
annonce et surtout la non non c'est toi
non c'est d'accord on sait moitié
raccrocheur et jeune ait un lien dans la
description de deux vidéos d'emi celle
qu'on va faire ensemble juste après et
celle qu'elle a sorti le jour où nous
serons dans cette vidéo qui une vidéo
très intéressante mon stress énorme
bouton stress énorme si tu veux savoir
pourquoi les stresser en ce moment et
qu'elle va se jeter sur son téléphone
dès qu'on aura coupé va voir cette vidéo
allez très importante et très cool voilà
merci à toi merci à toute l'équipe et
lumière si aux lumières merci au
règlement intérieur merci à charlotte
merci à l'algorithme merci aux
démonétisation merci on vous aime au
revoir
alors ça par exemple cessé de ronces et
non à moi non mais alors excusez moi
c'est pas très cool parce que j'étais
quand même à vide au toit pu mettre mon
rond au cid jeu mais tombe on regarde je
mets ton coin jeux l'entourent c'est
magnifique
si j'étais pas venu te dire ça tu aurais
pas vu mon rendu vous service est vrai
c'est pas très cool est ce qu'ils savent
qu'ils peuvent appuyer dessus même
depuis leur téléphone tu crois ben je
pense pas j'espère pour eux